hurry the president brought down the
house tonight in Florida Pensacola the
White House billed the rally as the
campaign style event for Trump but it
was also held so close to the Alabama
border it also served as a rally for
embattled GOP Senate candidate Roy Moore
Alabama's special election is held on
Tuesday here are a few highlights from
the raucous night in Florida tonight
we're going to speak straight to the
American people and cut right through
the fake news media right there right
now I think it's going to be very hard
for somebody to beat us in a few years
can you imagine now we're only talking
about a few years all you have to say is
with us it goes up with them it goes
down and that's the end of the election
right did you see all the corrections
the media's been making they say sorry
we made up they've been doing that all
year they never apologized maybe that
comes with being the president I don't
know
they took this fraud ster from ABC they
suspended him for a month they should
have fired him for what a hero he drove
the stock market down 350 points in
minutes which by the way tells you they
really liked me right what do you think
of it you know what he costs people and
I said to everybody get yourself a
lawyer and sue ABC nurse sue and then
CNN apologized just a little while ago
they apologized oh thank you see it and
thank you so much you should have been
apologizing for the last two years
these resistors resist Hillary resisted
and you know what happened you lost the
election in a landslide
but you know what they're really
resistant they're resisting the will of
the American people it's being proven we
have a rigged system doesn't happen so
easy but this system going to be a lot
of changes this is a rig this is a
rigged system this is a sick system from
the inside and you know there's no
country like our country but we have a
lot of sickness in some of our
institutions it's wrong and dangerous
for congressional Democrats to hold
troop funding hostage for amnesty
letting people pour into our country we
don't know who they are we don't know
where they come from you saw what
happened with beautiful Kate Steinle
that was a total miscarriage of justice
he didn't know it was a gun the real
changes that we're facing are the drugs
and the gangs pouring into our country
the millions of people overstaying their
visas chain migration that costs
taxpayers billions and billions of
dollars and sanctuary cities that set
free violent criminal aliens all over
our country and protect them
[Applause]
people come in and they're not
necessarily good like the man that ran
over the animal that ran over many
people in New York City we have to end
chain migration we have to end chain
migration but one by one we're finding
the illegal alien drug dealers the gang
members the thieves the criminals and
the killers preying on our children
preying on everybody and we are throwing
them the hell out of our country or were
putting them in prison
and because our borders now are strong
as they should be and they're going to
get much stronger we will not let these
people back in how many people here are
from the great state of Alabama did you
see what happened today you know the
yearbook did you see that there was a
little mistake made she started writing
things in the yearbook what are we gonna
do Gloria Allred any time you see her
you know something's going wrong
we cannot afford this country the future
of this country cannot afford to lose a
seat in the very very close United
States and we can't afford it for we
can't afford to have a Liberal Democrat
who is completely controlled by Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer we can't
[Applause]
his name is Jones and he's their total
puppet and everybody knows it he will
never ever vote for us we need somebody
in that Senate seat who will vote for
our make America great again agenda we
want jobs jobs jobs so get out and vote
for Roy Moore our troops don't wear a
foreign uniform and we will never
surrender our rights to international
tribunals we won't do that
we proudly sing the star-spangled banner
our brave troops fight and die for the
red white and blue and we protect and
preserve the American Constitution that
we cherish
I've said it so often that my job is not
to be President of the world my job is
to be President of the United States of
America we need some love in the country
I'd love to bring both sides together if
that's possible there's a lot of hatred
out there but I would love to be able to
bring both sides together the same
failed voices in Washington who opposed
our movement right from the beginning
are the same people who have undermined
the credibility of our government
institutions the Washington insiders who
opposed our movement are the same people
who sacrificed our sovereignty our
wealth our borders look at our country
they've had their chance at running this
country and they failed our guys did
amazing edits on that that's all I can
say they turn that around so fast Bravo
to the team